[Music]
hello everyone it is time for another
Collider interview I am pairing Emma off
we're at the Telluride kiya supper suite
and we are here with the team behind
promising young woman how are you guys
doing great Perry great pairing we have
to pass that same one down hands down
one of my most anticipated movies of the
festival at the time of this taping I am
planning to see it this evening and I'm
very excited for you guys especially
based on that first trailer which like
totally swept me up in the style and
energy just in case anybody out there
does not know what promising young woman
is yet would you mind doing the honors
and given the 101 of course I'm very bad
at this because it's quite difficult to
describe promising a woman is a dark
comedy revenge thriller about a young
woman who goes to night clubs pretends
to be very very drunk and waits for
people to take her home sounds pretty
accurate based on the trailer even
though I am expecting some surprises
along the way yeah I think so it's one
of those movies I think it is better to
kind of go in with very little knowing
very little yeah it seems like a very
ambitious movie for your feature
directorial debut so can you tell me
about making that choice and also about
you know as a new director kind of
getting the go-ahead to jump into
something like this I mean it's so much
of it is it's really difficult you know
you write something you make something
you hope to make it and if you're lucky
enough you find people who kind of
believe in it and a happy to like
support you and I was very lucky in the
producers lucky chap and film nation and
focus we're just always really behind it
and very they really supported the more
like outlandish or you know unusual
decisions it was it was um yeah it was
amazing and then you know once you get
like Carey Mulligan and Bo Burnham on
board and all the like incredible cast
it just becomes its own like magical
thing that's what's really exciting is
you know something on the page you can
always you can always kind of hope that
you always hoped in your head to try and
make the thing in your head as real as
close as it can be but when you get
really brilliant people involved
everyone actually in this it's better
than you imagined because they're they
just bring so much to it with these two
I would imagine that being the case bow
after having directed your first feature
film does that change how you look at
scripts from a first-time feature
director and whether or not you want to
sign on for something like that oh no I
mean you know yeah I'm not like choosing
between a bunch of big stuff coming my
way I mean I was like I didn't think I
was gonna be acting anytime soon and
then they were just like do you want a
chemistry with Carey Mulligan and I was
like sure that sounds fun and I'll
humiliate myself and and then it was
really great I'm an emerald she was
really great and even after the audition
I was like that's enough like that's
good for me I'm like happy and then they
asked me to do it I was like oh no but
no no I mean like I certainly was not on
set thinking like a director or anything
like that like III I had enough to worry
about just as an actor to and it's like
this is such a story like I could never
have written this script I could have
never directed this movie so like that
was never in my mind you know I was just
very excited to be an actor and just
service emeralds vision and so like yeah
I mean that's that's all I had to worry
about did you two know each other before
jumping into that chemistry read no we
never met we met you know chemistry
turned down Drive so I was we had almost
worked together but I was like I ain't
wearing those gloves can you do a remake
of drive with you as the lead that's
cool peein jacket my head now carry
there might be something in the mix you
have such a lengthy resume that I might
be missing but when I watched the
trailer I got the sense that like you've
never done anything quite like this role
before so what did you find to be the
most challenging new thing as far as
being in this movie yeah no I know I
haven't I mean I haven't it's really
rare to find really complex female
characters sounds like such a sort of
tranqued I think that it really is
really hard to find a woman who isn't
really one-dimensional
or 2-dimensional and for her the journey
that she goes on on what you know where
she's coming from and sort of she's so
surprising and she was such a puzzle to
figure out and was owning I was only
able to figure her out with emerald
there was just it was it made me nervous
in a really good way but now I haven't I
don't think I've ever it was sort of
probably the scariest endeavor you know
on screen certainly that I've kind of
tried what were some of the first
questions you had for emerald after your
first read of the script because again
just from my impression of the trailer
it does seem like a very visual stylish
story that maybe you didn't get from the
page but comes through when you're on
set and then in the Edit well emeralds
had sort of visual references for how
she wanted to look and how she want
cassie to look so that that kind of gave
me immediately i sort of understood the
world that we were in and that was a
world that i don't think you've seen
before and so that was really exciting
and also had this amazing playlist that
emerald have made with all the music
that she kind of heard in her mind when
she was writing it and and and and some
of which does end up featuring in the
film so I feel like I sort of stepped
into it and the minute I heard the music
and saw the pictures and met emerald I
was completely yeah so invested and
excited so we happen to be seeing a lot
of movies that are covering kind of a
toxic culture in a timely manner what is
it about your movie that does so in a
different fashion that we're not getting
elsewhere
it's an interesting question I think
again it's a difficult one too it's
really difficult thing to talk about
because it's hard you don't want to give
the game away and so much of it is I
would say the thing the thing that I can
say when I was writing it was I wanted
to make an honest film and a film about
a real woman and I didn't want something
easy and I don't think it is it
something can be fun and it can be
beautiful and it can be exciting and
thrilling and funny
but it can also be really hard and and I
think that's the kind of movie I wanted
to make what I didn't want was to make
something that you know that you left
the movie theater and thought well great
I don't need to think about this again I
you know I think it's all the movies I
love you want people to leave the movie
theater and sit down opposite whoever
they went with at dinner and think like
I don't know I don't know that's that's
what you want and so that's what I hope
this movie is it's it's um yeah not
quite what it seems it makes me even
more excited to see it tonight and then
to continue the conversation for you to
how does it feel being directed by
someone who's also an accomplished actor
can you feel the difference on set and
what does someone like Emeril do for you
as actors that some other directors
maybe don't yeah i I've been directed by
I was directed by Paul Dano and I had a
similar thing where you just feel I mean
it's like it's there's an initial
feeling of feeling sort of intimidated
by it and vert you know that somehow
with the director who doesn't act you
sort of feel like well you try it make
like you do really mean like you can
kind of find a sort of self-defense
mechanism of with your own sort of own
sort of anxiety about what you're doing
work wise but so you know it is it sort
of intimidating on the on the outside
and then it is the most wonderful
helpful brilliant intuitive kind of vibe
and there were so many occasions where I
knew that emerald knew what I was
struggling with and how to fix it or if
not how to fix it how to try and get rid
of it or and
I think all of that was I mean as a
director
even if Emeril didn't act I think she'd
be an extraordinary director but I think
having that added element of
understanding what it's like to be in
the scene and suddenly have no idea what
were doing or hate everything you're
doing or want to change everything
I think she knows how to get in the
middle of that and and sort it out and
and also I think just as a director
outside of the the acting aspect Emerald
was someone who was so encouraging and
made everything so safe I don't think
you could make a film like this unless
you felt like you couldn't do anything
wrong so there was no there was nothing
you could do that was too big or too
silly or too because she was she was so
in command of the whole situation I just
felt complete and utter trust that's a
really a rare thing just with that idea
in mind of working with a director who
is acting experience and maybe vice
versa in your case if you could have a
little more know-how from someone else's
point of view in the crew like learn
anything else about another position on
set what would you choose and why you
choose a focus Buller because I have
absolutely no idea what they do like how
they do dial thing it's it's like it's
nuclear physics to me I don't understand
it people on the set thought I was crash
serviced it legitimately did the home
was like a you crap like I'm like I know
I look like someone that should just be
like giving you brown rice but
unfortunately like I'm pretty high on
the call sheet so I'd like to I think
what's really cool I'll say about it
said I'm shining because who cares about
me is that like my father like a
construction works in construction and
like what he came to a set for the first
time to see how collaborative like you
are learning from each other you are it
actually isn't totally compartmentalize
it feels like it's like a very rare
place and people think like well you
know father was just full of these
snotty people it's like no it's like a
lot a bunch of people from a different
lot of different trades totally working
together and learning from each other so
I think whenever I'm on set I learn from
other people it's an actually of so much
downtime so you're usually just like
looking at
looking at people work hard so I had
someone bring this up recently because
like actors get to work with actors on
set but a director very regularly gets
to work right there with another
director so if you had the opportunity
to be a fly on the wall of another
director said who would you choose Paul
Thomas Anderson I think without a shadow
of a doubt he's just the best ever
very very good I just ya know I just
love to watch I was hoping you guys
could highlight a little more of your
ensemble here everyone gets showcased in
that trailer and it is extremely
exciting the group that you've assembled
so is there anybody in the in Samba that
you know we're gonna see in a way that
we haven't seen them before or brought
more out of the role than you even
expected
Adam Brody's pretty special he opens the
movie only like he can we the history I
mean I think the thing for Fermi was
that like this was a kind of grotesque
way of me just before ending all the
people I've admired for years so Carrie
just is the most talented genius also
very hot and funny so you know
immediately wanted to be best friends bo
I mean I've just I'm gonna get I was
gonna give you a lovely compliment he
doesn't deserve a compliment um you know
getting like Jennifer Coolidge and
Connie Britton and Laverne Cox and
Alfred Molina and these are people
genuinely that you'd have any worldís
dreams think we'll ever say Shannon
Molly Shannon you know it's like the
list goes on and on and on but the thing
that I really wanted to do for this film
is just the certainly the films I love
is like having people looking at people
particularly comment comedy actors are
so talented comedy is the hardest thing
to do particularly make it selling
something in its same joke again and
again and so getting getting people you
know that we love and feel really
comfortable with to do stuff that's
quite challenging just seems so
interesting cuz isn't you know the thing
for me is that I wanted to do with this
movie is say like it's so easy for
things to be brought black and white
when you don't like someone
but when he loves someone it's [ __ ]
impossible so I think the thing is is
that part of it was creating a world of
people we love and then putting the
thumbscrews on I guess just like upping
the anticipation for tonight I can't
wait I do have I got a couple upcoming
questions for you first how are you
doing on your directing career when are
we gonna see something next soon yeah I
don't know
just okay I'm waiting I'm a very
impatient person so keep that in mind as
you go please please yes yes bother me
and admittedly someone fed me this
question because I have to watch the
crown I will I swear after I get back
from Sundance will we see more of
Camilla and Charles on the next season
of the crown
oh yeah totally absolutely it's we're
doing it right now it's amazing it's
amazing I wasn't gonna let that wig go
down easy I'm like looking at the the
person's reaction to make sure I got an
answer that excited him I think yeah
guys thank you so much for your time
today
promising young woman I'm so excited I
can't wait to see it you should be too
do not leave this interview without
liking and sharing it from Park City at
the kiyose supper suite thanks for
watching we'll see you soon with more
interviews